So after Bernie's win in New Hampshire, you
had coming out of the woodwork endless.
Supposedly enlightened takes on the meaning
of this victory for Bernie, the meaning of
this loss for Biden, the of this surge by
Amy Klobuchar, and I don't want to be rude
or disrespectful to anybody, but the meaning
of this is actually quite limited and most
of these enlightened hot takes are not particularly
enlightened.
Bernie won a primary by 1.5 percentage points
tied in the number of delegates with Pete
Buddha, judge nine each, and now has two popular
vote wins in the two primaries that we've
had so far.
The future is wide open.
Okay.
The circumstances of this particular primary,
in addition to this, just being the first
to tell us very little about who is ultimately
going to be the nominees.
So let's go through some of the talking points.
There are pro and anti Bernie talking points
in there.
There's a whole bunch of different stuff.
Let's talk through them.
Some of the takes are just straight up dumb.
Okay.
One was the results from New Hampshire are
really bad for Bernie because in 2016, he
got 60% of the primary vote and this time
he got 25% of the primary vote.
Come on.
Okay.
There were two real candidates in 2016.
Yeah.
Uh, I think, um, uh, you know, you had um,
uh, what, what was it, the dude's name?
Uh, vermin Supreme got 300 votes or something.
In New Hampshire in 2016, there were really
two candidates this time.
You have five people coming away with delegates
in New Hampshire to say Bernie is doing poorly
because he got 26% instead of 60.
Last time is a meaningless take.
It tells us nothing whatsoever.
A second talking point, Bernie underperformed
the polling.
Bernie was a Bernie underperformed.
His results underperformed polling by about
three percentage points.
Thus, clearly Bernie is on the decline.
Bernie underperformed by 2.8 he still won
the delegate count for him and Pete is identical
nine each from New Hampshire and almost every
delegate is still up for grabs.
There's a candidate in Michael Bloomberg who
hasn't even been on the ballot yet, who is
pulling 15% nationally now, which we will
talk about a little bit later.
The Bernie underperformance of two points
to 2.8 points is meaningless in the big picture.
Don't fall for that anti Bernie take.
Now you also have some pro Bernie talking
points that are not particularly meaningful.
I heard one floating around yesterday that
no candidate has lost when they win Iowa and
New Hampshire in recent history.
Now that may or may not be true depending
on how far back you go, but it's even a weird
technicality because Bernie did not get the
most delegates in Iowa, so by the way that
it is measured, Bernie didn't win Iowa.
Bernie did get the most votes.
Either way, it's a fight about something that's
not relevant.
It just does not actually tell us what's going
to happen in this primary.
Another talking point floating around is that
Bernie or Pete or whoever, that they can't
necessarily coalesce the nonwhite vote and
thus the results in the early white States
don't matter.
Well, if you look at the polling for Bernie,
it's very different than Pete with black voters
and Latino voters.
That's number one.
Just because there haven't been large Latino
and black populations that have voted yet,
doesn't mean that you can make that claim.
We do have polling about that.
It is true that the results in the early white
States reflect the demographics of those States,
but they're still important.
They dictate the publicity and the headlines
around the primary.
They can provide a PR lift and case in point,
we've seen that the support for candidates
from the black and Latino communities has
shifted as candidates have done better and
worse nationally and in the early primary.
So that's not a particularly good talking
point either.
Here's the reality and a lot of you are going
to be bored by the reality or you'll find
it sort of uninteresting because we want to
feel like everything's already happened and
really very little has the numbers.
So far, tell us some things and they don't
tell us other things.
The numbers so far suggest we will have four
to five candidates staying in this mathematically,
at least hypothetically viable for a while.
We should expect that five candidates already
have delegates.
I expect Tom Stier will get delegates in South
Carolina.
Uh, that will be a sixth candidate with delegates.
I expect Michael Bloomberg will get delegates
on super Tuesday.
He's pulling in the teens in Texas and Florida.
We'll talk about that later.
That's a bunch of delegates for Bloomberg.
So one thing so far is that this will likely
be a big field for a while.
Number two, the dynamics of this race could
change very quickly depending on what happens
with Michael Bloomberg.
His polling has exploded, which I want to
get to.
He had this horrible racist audio released
by Benjamin Dixon, our friend two days ago.
His campaign is trying to do crisis management
around the racist audio.
We will see how his polling is affected by
that, but right now, every indication that
Bloomberg will be a factor.
I still believe Bloomberg ends up third or
fourth in terms of total delegates.
By the time this is done, if Biden keeps failing
and Bloomberg comes in strong on super Tuesday,
the DNC establishment will have to make a
decision which will have a big impact on the
rest of the race and until they do, we won't
know what's going to happen.
Will the establishment abandoned Biden and
get behind Pete or Amy or will the establishment
abandoned Biden and get behind a Bloomberg
if Biden's failures continue?
These are real questions.
You know, whether the, whether a popular vote
win in Iowa and New Hampshire guarantees a
primary victory is not a particularly relevant
or interesting question.
This is a very different primary than one's
past.
Everyone wants to know now what the path is.
It's not knowable right now because of the
unique nature of this race, including that
we have a candidate who's not yet been on
any ballot, but it's polling as high as 17%
in a recent national poll.
That's Michael Bloomberg.
We'll look at those numbers a little bit later.
So far.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
I do want to
hear that.